[Musique]
je m'appelle sylvain rousseau cinquante
deux ans je suis exploitants de l'école
à partir de 10-12 ans je suivais déjà
mon père la chasse et puis j'ai pris le
virus quoi le virus sur la chasse
[Musique]
je m'appelle serge manceau je suis né
ici je suis la troisième génération
j'ai 81 ans j'étais exploitants ricol
est ici pendant une cinquantaine
d'années et je suis donc chasseurs
surtout bien joueurs aussi
tu m'appelles simon manceau j'ai 16 ans
en plus tard je voudrais faire
agriculteurs je suis en études agricoles
au lycée donc mes passions
c'est la chasse la pêche et et le foot
et c'est vrai que j'adore par dessus
tout la chasse
on
[Musique]
quelques jours à peine après l'ouverture
de la chasse aux pigeons sylvain serge
ici mon install déjà à leur champ de
bataille
on va mettre les pigeons les formes des
pigeons ont devant lui rend faire coup
double on va mettre des corbeaux des
corbeaux floqué derrière nous on peut
tirer et les pigeons les corbeaux la
meilleure période pour tirer ses oiseaux
migrateurs est courte
un mois tout au plus le lieu de chasse
n'a pas été choisi au hasard s'ils
veulent juste de moissonner ce champ et
puis j'en raffole du temps au sol aussi
bien que quand il est sur pied ou 6 ou
alors quand il est battu quand il est
battu il ya toujours du grand art est
des capitulards est et puis alors la
bomba on s'amuse on s'amuse à cette
période-là et pour attirer le gibier il
faut ruser
donc là je prépare les pigeons pour être
sûr balancier donc c'est des pigeons à
nous des pigeons les appelants qu'on
appelait je prépare les pattes hier pour
mettre autour de ses pattes et ensuite
de le mettre sur le balancier est comme
ça après on tient sur une corde et ça
déséquilibre le pigeon pour pour que les
elle s'ouvre et ça fait 1 1 là clan qui
fait mine de se poser c'est une chance
et ça attire les autres pigeons au début
chasser le pigeon mais plus timidement
si vous voulez au pied des hauts près du
pied d'un chêne et au fur et à mesure on
s'est aperçu qu'en mettant des formes ça
les attirer alors on s'est perfectionnée
disons avec sylvain et puis ici si bon
petit à petit on s'est amélioré
à porte
en raison de son jeune âge simon n'a pas
encore le droit de chasser seul c'est
son grand-père qui le parraine et lui
prête son fusil j'ai passé mon permis de
chasse accompagnée l'année dernière donc
c'est un peu plus simple que le permis
de chasse et une journée de formation
donc que pratiques n'ont pas pas cette
théorie soit chasse avec mon père soit
avec mon grand père il est adroit très
adroit oui oui si pour le fusil moi je
pense doit pas le prendre
théoriquement c'est pour respecter
attention un pigeon cette chasse à tirer
leur favorite mais ce coup ci le tableau
de chasse restera humble si corbeau les
quatre qui joue à c'est pas mal on a
connu on a connu mieux on a connu pire
aussi un nom oui pour deux heures de
chasse c'est bien pour serge qui s'est
contenté d'observer c'est d'être en
famille qui compte savait depuis 60 ans
j'en ai tiré des coups de fusil alors
mais je suis content de voir du gibier
d'evra chasse et simple du plaisir
[Musique]
voilà c'est prêt simon vient tout juste
d'avoir 16 ans il a enfin le droit de
chasser seul
c'est une étape importante dans la vie
d'un jeune chasseur est l'occasion de se
faire offrir son premier fusil de varier
un peu d'émotion je suis juré d'avoir sa
gelée prix justement parce que c'est un
super posé que c'était plus plus simple
et plus sécurisant pour pour la chasse
qu'un semi automatique
c'est principalement pour ça mais c'est
vrai que je trouve jolie c'est pour ça
que j'ai pris aussi chaque arme et
adaptés à la morphologie de son
propriétaire
l'essai du fusil est un passage obligé
simon doit tester le sien pour le
connaître et l'apprivoiser donc là c'est
vraiment le tir instinctif voir si on
est bien en alignement
[Applaudissements]
le premier tir semble concluant couvre
le centre de gerbe au lieu d'être ici un
tout petit peu plus ici mais on peut
vous revient la zone visée donc c'est
pas mal quoi
simon gardera sans doute ce fusil toute
sa vie une arme mise entre ses mains par
ses parents qui sont conscients du
danger il a passé son permis c'est
surtout sur la sécurité c'est vrai mais
la chasse au gros gibier ça me fait
énormément peur après le tir à balle
tout ça ça me fait peur mais bon et en
plus qu'il est jeune mais quand mon mari
part à la chasse je suis pas tranquille
non plus à cet été nous a donné un bon
coup de main la travailler avec nous sur
l'exploration et aux lieux avait dire on
te paye pas bon offrir à tonton pourront
les fusils j'ai eu le même cadeau étant
jeune lorsque j'avais 18 ans
on perd mais offert mon premier fusil
bon c'est dit puis on n'a qu'un fils
donc s'est dit oui c'est presque normal
pour nous vous allez poignée anglais
allez-y
un beau cadeau à 1200 euros pour fêter
les 16 ans de simon âge à partir duquel
il sera considéré comme un chasseur
capable et responsable
les monceaux chasse principalement sur
leurs terres 150 hectares de champs et
de bois où vivent une multitude
d'animaux la régulation des populations
fait partie de leur vie de chasseur faut
pas trop les météorites
sinon je te dise à fait là c'est la voie
la table de serge capture le renard
depuis 25 ans l'animal est classé
nuisible en raison des dégâts qu'il peut
causer ce matin là le grand père et son
petit fils installe un piège à lacet
avec une dinde comme un pas la ferraille
il a sans la ferraille
quand je mets la caméra je vais la
mettre tout à l'heure la caméra lassus
le piquer on les boîtes et tourner
autour
il s'en est 100 euros ils reviennent le
lendemain ils sont encore ils approchent
un petit peu plus près et puis s'en vont
puis c'est au bout de quelques jours
fini par passer devant le renard est
rusé et très difficile à attraper
alors quand on est piégeurs il faut être
patient et rester motivé des fois faut
attendre 8 15 jours trois semaines avant
d'avoir na avant même de l'avoir manqué
moi ça m'est arrivé deux fois depuis
plus de 20 ans j'ai tendu le matin et le
lendemain matin j'avais arnat mais ça
m'est arrivé que deux fois
ça sert à ça tout peut arriver
alors les gars abandonne au bout de et à
quinze jours ils vont après 1 jour sur 2
pire ils se figurent qu'au bout de trois
jours ils vont avoir un renard mais dont
on peut rêver un si gros bon on va
cacher la dan symons chaque piégeurs à
sa propre technique pour serge le tas de
fumier on fer à cheval semble bien
fonctionner dans ces périodes fastes ils
capturaient jusqu'à 40 de renard par an
[Musique]
la ferme des manceaux abrite aujourd'hui
les souvenirs de cinq générations
d'agriculteurs passionné de chasse
simon a été plongée dans le parler son
plus jeune âge
j'allais à la chasse à 3 4 ans et on
faisait des chasses en plein jeu le soir
j'étais rincé parce que tout le monde
tous marcher moi j'étais obligé de
suivre derrière quoi et puis tout petit
comme ça je suis je vais dehors j'ai
joué à la chasse tout seul même quand
j'ai pas mon père me chasser jal à la
chasse avec un fusil en plastique 1 à
d'autres c'était des voitures mais moi
non savez que j'aime ont fusé en
plastique
et puis j'étais content avec ça
étudiant lycée agricole son avenir est
tout tracé dans quelques années il
reprendra l'exploitation familiale
mon objectif c'est de m'installer là sur
sur les terres de mon grand-père avant
et puis de mon père aujourd'hui déjà
hâte renfermé et journée en classe ça
m'énerve
donc si je devrais faire mon métier dans
un bureau c'est pas possible
[Musique]
le jeune homme fera donc perdurer un
mode de vie rurale et traditionnelle
en france la moyenne d'âge des
agriculteurs tout comme celle des
chasseurs et de 50 ans
depuis toujours au mois de novembre la
famille montceau organise sur ses terres
une partie de chasse unique
c'est une charge spéciale aux lièvres 11
ans mais que du plomb elle n'a lieu
qu'une seule fois par an car l'animal
doit être préservé et c'est simon le
plus jeune de la bande qui donne les
instructions milieu bien chef dans le
secteur le nombre de lièvres a chuté en
trois ans maladie ou prédation trop
importante
on ne connaît pas encore les raisons de
ce phénomène en général on a toujours du
lieu si vous voulez on pourrait les
faire tous les droits là mon fils et mon
petit fils
on préfère faire plaisir aux amis je
peux me vois pas avoir de liev à la main
je vais tirer si j si l'occasion se
présente mais tout le monde a sa chance
pour la première traite de la journée
les chasseurs se place à l'orée d'un
bois
[Musique]
les traqueurs lâche les chiens pour
lever les lièvres et les pousser en
direction des tireurs après une heure de
chasse sylvain n'est toujours pas
dégainé william and population un essai
général général s'il y avait un bon
territoire à perdre au 1 en faisait
autant de perdreaux que le lièvre on
faisait 20 aliev et puis car hasard d'un
perdreau where we can avait perdre on le
fait on les faisait un passage au
montreux 25 ans en arrière aussi pour
simon c'est la chance du débutant leur
premier liège ouais ognier bout de cinq
minutes que j'étais arrivé juste en
bordure d'un petit prêt donc le lièvre
il est arrivé au bord du petit presse
comme celle allongée donc j'ai attendu
d'avoir mes angles pour tirer puis après
quand il m'a dépassé j'ai tiré dans le
champ derrière voilà un animal abattu
doit être identifié tous les ans la
préfecture attribue aux manceaux un plan
de chasse un droit de tuer
cette saison ils peuvent tirer hui
lièvre et pas un de plus
dans cet univers de chasseurs
essentiellement masculin monique la
femme de la maison joue son rôle
c'est elle qui prépare tout
naturellement le repas pour la bande de
copains non jeu pour fait d'efforts ça
me paraît logique normal je pense bon
c'est pareil je devais avoir ça dans la
peau aussi certainement et ça nous fait
vraiment plaisir d'inviter des amis des
chasseurs
c'est à partir de la vie de tous les
jours
j'espère que le gorille de continuité
avec 6 mo j'espère qu'il rencontrera une
femme qui veulent bien faire ce que j'ai
fait fin de la matinée
tous n'ont pas tiré un coup de fusil
mais l'essentiel est ailleurs
si agréable de retrouver des copains une
fois par an pour faire cette journée de
chasse ça fait plaisir monsieur manceau
trois générations sur un même territoire
c'est magnifique si vous voulez
aujourd'hui c'est difficile d'avoir des
jeunes chasseurs et je pense que
monsieur manceau le grand-père a bien
fait son sa succession
de retour à la fermer avant de se mettre
à table on prend la traditionnelle photo
du tableau de chasse le repas est un
moment convivial on se raconte les
histoires des années passées mais on
imagine aussi celles à venir
bien qu'au fil du temps l'âge mais on ne
cesse de s'imposer autour de la table
c'est vrai que les jeunes ils sont un
petit peu réticent bon à part nous
sommes une famille de chasseurs mais
sinon si c'est pas une famille de
chasseurs c'est difficile de s'intégrer
dans les chasses dans ces difficiles
quand même
être fils ou fille de chasseurs jouent
un rôle primordial dans la pérennité de
la chasse traditionnelle
aujourd'hui deux pratiquants sur trois
ont grandi dans ce milieu et c'est parmi
les agriculteurs que l'héritage de la
chasse a le plus de poids la famille
montceau a su faire perdurer la
tradition durant cinq générations
mais pour combien de temps encore